qu'il se livre à moi avec autant
franchise sont hélas bien il a bien
après a vu les très flippant alors alors
guillaume a une fascination
il est très très très attiré par
une sorte de film
ça va pas tu m'as dit bobo vos bouts est
ce que vous connaissez les films les
chimères
[Rires]
en fait il des deux en main sa faune des
femmes hommes c'est un des femmes avec
des
chutes mortelles d'idées poitrine de
femme ailée sexe d'homme à la maison et
en fait on
a tourné tandja ne réponde à ses
ambitions on passera plus jamais une
france
métisse il ya un deuxième effet kiss
cool encore parce que quand il m'a dit
ça moi j'ai d'abord jeu s'il fait très
bien et pourquoi
benjamin castaldi est à côté il a dit
oui moi aussi je kiffe temps
c'est la saison